we need to stop referring to what has
happened over the past year and a half
as kovid i've been guilty of it too but
we need to stop it you know when people
say oh we had all of these plans for
last year but then kovid happened or oh
yes that was going all well and good but
but then covid and so you know we
couldn't live our lives anymore
what happened last year is not because
of covid that huge political and social
revolution it is because
of the lockdowns and the other measures
that cynical and opportunistic
politicians implemented using kovid as
an excuse and that's not some wild crazy
conspiracy theory that is a strategy
that we all knew the left was using even
at the time and that right now even the
white house is admitting
the president wants to make fundamental
change in our economy and he feels
coming out of the pandemic is exactly
the time to do that and if we don't do
it now if we don't address uh the cost
of child care to go back to josh's
question earlier if we don't uh address
the climate crisis if we don't ensure
that universal pre-k is a reality now
uh
we're not going to have the same
opportunity to do it for some time
we're not going to have the opportunity
and that's what covet is for the left
it's an opportunity sometimes people
have called it a great reset they've
called it this major revolution but it's
not the wacky conspiracy theorists it's
the left who is admitting that that's
what they're doing the left never lets a
crisis go to waste perhaps we ought to
learn that lesson perhaps we ought to
use crises to our political advantage as
well i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from it ain't like
that bro we was just texting
that's the name i like that comment too
but but the comment is quote the
funniest thing is when liberals label
you a quote conspiracy theorist for for
calling their plan an agenda
right
when you say hey look the libs said they
were going to do this thing and then
they are doing this thing and this is
where that thing is going they call you
a conspiracy theorist even if you're
playing their own words against them
that that you cannot do if you ever call
out the reality of what of what they are
doing they will label you as delusional
and try to get people to ignore what
you're saying but i think it's time we
start paying attention because the
economy in particular is collapsing all
around us and you know one great way to
hedge your investments against those
economic crazy times
acre gold despite what you might be
seeing in the establishment media and
the corporate press right now
everything is not tickety-boo actually
prices are all over the place inflation
is going up the economy is really in
shambles good way to hedge your
investments against economic craziness
is to invest in physical precious metals
now i know you're thinking michael all
right i don't got it like that i don't i
don't have the kind of money in my couch
cushions to invest in physical gold what
if i told you you can do it for 30
dollars per month michael you lie calm
down calm down i don't lie acre gold is
figured out this ingenious way to invest
in physical gold without coming out of
pocket all at once you can do it for as
little as 30 bucks a month you can also
get their 100 a month subscription to a
5 grand gold bar if you want to up the
ante but whatever you want to do you
subscribe when your gold stash reaches
the price of their gold bars they will
discreetly ship acre gold to your door
make sure you check this out today you
can do it by going to get acre gold dot
com slash knowles start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
that url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre go check
it out right now get acre gold dot com
slash knowles and thank you aker gold
for supporting the show
what more evidence do we need you have
the white house coming out and this by
the way
you know poor jen saki was getting in
this exchange with a reporter she's got
a lot to defend right now and a lot of
what she has to defend is indefensible
the border collapsing turmoil let's go
brandon enchants happening all over the
country nay all over the world and the
economy falling apart and she says look
look we're trying to completely upend
the economy we're trying to reorder
society all right we've got to do it now
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
so cut us a little bit of slack oopsie
daisy was i supposed to say that
whoopsie was did i say the quiet part
out loud because what has covid
represented
yes it has represented this mass
hysteria
over all segments of society for a virus
that has a very very low infection work
mortality right or infection fatality
rate rather
yes it represents a reordering of
political rights yes it's a massive
power grab from the bureaucracy taking
away lots of liberties that we once had
but
let's not forget the economic aspect
this
covid lockdown phenomenon
has been the largest transfer of wealth
from the lower and middle classes to a
select few very wealthy powerful people
in our nation's history
maybe well beyond our nation's history
just consider
amazon just consider your own behavior
with amazon
we now and for the past year and a half
have accelerated the trend of ordering
every freaking thing in the world from
amazon so much so that there's a book
paper shortage going on right now
because people are using so much more
cardboard because now instead of going
down the street to the store to order i
don't know to go buy a box of q-tips or
something even that you're going to
order from amazon right a major transfer
of wealth from small businesses to these
much larger conglomerates that can deal
with the world being shut down for a
year and a half
and those corporations have a radical
social agenda i just saw this the other
day just came to my attention on amazon
do you know that on amazon you can shop
by the identity
the political identities of
the business owners
what i mean by that is if you go on
amazon right now you can type in black
owned business just type it right into
the search bar and a big banner will
come up and it will say shop at
businesses owned by black people now
what does this mean i don't know does
this mean that black people need to own
a 50
51 maybe or 50 plus one vote stake in
the business what about what if it's 49
owned by white people but 51 owned by
black people is it still a black owned
business i don't know maybe you can go
to the amazon shop by category page and
see they've got links for black owned
businesses they've got links for
women-owned businesses so i was looking
through i said okay this is very very
woke uh what happens if i want to shop
at uh straight white guy owned
businesses i don't look i don't have any
particular
impulse to shop at straight like i own
businesses but what if i did
this is the new rule you're allowed to
to pick where you're gonna shop based on
the identity of the owner okay do to do
so i type it in and you'll be shocked to
find out it doesn't come up and then you
look on the page the shop by category
page it's nowhere to be found
because that would be racist if you go
to a
white-owned business page that's racist
if you go to a black-owned business page
very not racist anti-racist actually if
you go to a man-owned
business page sexist woman-owned
business page
not sexist
of course that is incoherent either they
both are racist or neither is racist
either they both are sexist or neither
is sexist and what it leads to is
something that we've seen
increasingly which is an official policy
of that much-maligned straight white guy
as the worst type of person who has ever
existed
of
of white people in particular but with
some other groups as well officially as
second-class citizens and with men
officially as second-class citizens the
clearest place of course to see this is
at university admissions which is that
if you are
a white guy or an asian guy for some
reason you will be disadvantaged you
will be put in
in a lower category if you're applying
to university than if you're a black
person or an hispanic person
if you're a man you will be put in a
lower especially if you're a straight
guy you'll be put in a lower category
you will be disadvantaged than if you
are a woman or you can claim some other
kind of victim status but that that is a
social hierarchy there you are saying
certain people are going to get certain
things and this this process that we are
in right now this radical social
transformation is accelerating that
we're all guilty of it but when you shop
at places like amazon you are
accelerating that trend now what is the
answer is the answer just never to shop
at amazon i don't even think that's
really feasible amazon just has too much
power so i don't think we need to say
let's go knock down amazon or never shop
there again but what we need to do is
wield political power to stop this stuff
because i don't want to live in a world
where we are defined by these radical
social
sexual and racial
hierarchies
and we are in i mean the one the one
thing jen saki's getting right here is
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
the economy is being reordered just just
in august we have got from cnbc
a report of a record
4.3 million workers quitting their jobs
and what we are told by the way is that
when 4.3 million workers quit their jobs
even with a labor shortage right there's
a 11 million person labor shortage going
on right now when all these workers quit
their jobs it's a sign
of economic strength that's actually how
the left is trying to spin this because
they say look people are quitting their
jobs because they're they're not worried
about getting another job well sure
we're in a labor shortage right now but
why why are they really quitting their
jobs might it have anything to do with
the powers that be the ruling class
telling people not to work
and then
telling people that if they don't get an
experimental drug for a virus that for
most people doesn't pose a grave threat
to them they're going to be fine they're
going to lose their jobs and then
telling employers to fine that they're
gonna have to pay fines if the workers
don't comply and then also the
government paying people not to work for
months and months well over a year now
on end might it have anything to do with
that and why why is the government doing
that is it sheer incompetence i don't
think so is it out of the goodness of
their heart i don't think so do you
remember a few years ago when when marco
rubio glitched out during that debate
and he said we must dispel with this
fiction barack obama doesn't know what
he's doing he knows exactly what he's
doing and chris christie called him out
and it was kind of the end of marco's
marco's presidential campaign well he
was right he had a point we need to
dispel with the fiction that the left is
incompetent that poor biden is just
incompetent he doesn't know what he's
doing these people know exactly what
they're doing they're using a crisis to
their advantage and we on the right are
letting them do it
southwest airlines has been
at the epicenter
of this economic turmoil over the past
few days and it's because on sunday we
covered it on monday on sunday a
thousand flights get cancelled for
southwest
and the day before that it was a whole
lot of flights were canceled and the day
after that a whole lot of flights were
canceled and southwest airlines
officially said it was because of
weather
but i don't know about you sunday was
perfectly beautiful where i was i don't
think there were any major storm systems
that moved in some other airlines didn't
have a problem
and
over the ensuing days what came out was
that there was a sick in that there were
pilots and notably air traffic
controllers in places that were in
particular affecting southwest that
called in sick because they didn't want
to comply with the vaccine mandate
and so what are you going to do you've
got a vaccine mandate at the level of
the federal government
right so that could affect the air
traffic controllers that's a direct
mandate saying get the get the vaccine
or lose your job but then you've got the
the cowardly
byzantine complicated vaccine mandate
that that brocco barack obama that that
joe biden instituted on the
employees of companies with more than
100 employees and that was by ordering
the occupational safety and health
administration to order the companies
with these this number of employees to
order the employees to take the vaccine
or the companies would have to pay 14
000 fines now the fine has actually been
increased a whole lot more and so over
the ensuing days southwest sort of came
clean and the ceo went on tv and said
look i hate the mandate the only reason
i'm pushing the mandate on my employees
is because joe biden is making me and we
can't afford to pay these gazillion
dollar fines every single time we are
caught violating the mandates
and that's half true
okay but it's not totally true
it's yes joe biden started this he
instituted this or he he made this
ridiculous proclamation that all of
these companies are going to have to go
along with the vaccine mandate
but they're not actually enforcing that
right now osha that agency that was
tasked with doing it hasn't even really
issued the formal rules
basically it was just a big press event
it's like a big press release and i
think what it did in effect was give
woke ceos
some cover to demand that their
employees take the vaccine while being
able to blame it on joe biden now i
don't think that the ceo of southwest is
necessarily a big woke guy they've
actually done some pretty conservative
things in the past so i'm not not really
accusing him of that but i think it is a
wake-up call
for for other companies here
you don't need to go along with this
look at us okay i don't want to toot our
own horn here at the daily wire but when
that when that
mandate came out
what did what did the daily wire say
jeremy boring the god king here at the
daily wire went on the air and he had
three words for joe biden and those
words were not let's go brandon actually
those words were let's go brand and they
were the true meaning of let's go
brandon we said no thank you buddy we're
not going to comply with this sues take
us to court we hired a bunch of lawyers
and look if we were the fastest growing
conservative media company in the
country but we have
relatively limited resources compared
with an entity like southwest airlines
or any of these other large entities so
if we can lawyer up and we can stand
firm why can't you i actually think that
these other companies can and i don't
want them just passing the buck onto joe
biden the ceos need to stand up if
you're not going to do it now when are
you going to do it this is a
generational opportunity that that the
left sees and they're going to try to
take full advantage of it and they're
even bragging about it now from the
white house and so they've got to stand
up and they've got to they've got to
have the courage to defend the rights of
their employees
and don't blame joe biden if you're not
going to do it yeah joe biden is a not a
great guy and he's doing a lot of
terrible things
but what are you doing business owners
what are you doing ceos
it was it was encouraging to see the
southwest ceo go on tv and say it's all
biden's fault in a certain sense because
it shows that even in our corrupt
culture
these powerful people can still turn on
joe biden
because they're feeling the heat from
their own guys but we need to see a lot
more of that
otherwise the left is going to succeed
at radically changing our world as a
result of covet cnn right now is is
referring
to the time before the covid lockdowns
as i kid you not the before times
capital b
capital t i don't know how many of you
are history buffs but in our
civilization traditionally the way that
we refer to the
dating you know to to
the years in our calendar
is with a bc referring to the time
before christ and a.d
the ano domini the year the year of our
lord right that's the traditional way
and then the libs came in
and the atheists and they said no how
dare you we can't refer to christ
this the central figure in our
civilization and in uh the entire cosmos
we can't refer that would be very wrong
so we're going to refer to the common
era so then they thought this was very
clever because they could change bc to
bce this is before the common era and
then after the common era but no we've
gotten even crazier than that stupid
dating we're now into the b
b t and
a t i don't know the before times and
the after times what cnn tweeted was
quote if you hoped grocery stores this
fall and winter would look like they did
in the before times with limitless
options stretching out before you in the
snack drink candy and frozen foods
aisles get ready for some disappointing
news it's not going to happen and it's
they're blaming it on supply chain and
it's and it's all because of
because of covid it's not because of
covid
the the time before the lockdowns does
not need to be the absolutely
unrelatable before times and the time
we're living in now doesn't need to be
radically different because of kovid
kovid relative to other scourges that
humanity has faced is just not that big
a freaking deal i'm not saying it it
doesn't exist i'm not saying it doesn't
pose a threat especially to some people
but relative to other problems that our
world has faced i don't know bubonic
plague or i don't know smallpox even or
out of wars it's just not
that big a freaking deal relative to
those other issues certainly not so much
so that we need to
say that this is the defining event
in our
history
but it can be that big a deal
it can be that big a deal if we allow it
to
i think that if the left has its
druthers
then
2019 and all the years before that will
just seem so different oh my gosh back
in those days we used to drive a lot of
places we used to go into work we used
to see egypt can you imagine going and
seeing each other's faces and smiling
breathing the same filthy air that the
peasants would breathe oh those were
crazy before times when you would see
people and not just have everyone walk
around muzzled all the time when you
would go into an office building go into
a school building and actually interact
with one oh it was crazy before
thankfully now though we all live in our
pods and eat the bugs and just give all
of our money to a handful of oligarchs
who who control speech who control our
elections who control oh that's so much
better we do you know we used to go vote
on election day in our republic oh my
goodness in the crazy before times now
we just uh fill in mail-in votes with
with no verification and we trust the
ruling class to conduct fair elections
when even barack obama admitted to us a
few years before
we went into the post before times that
that would pose a great threat to
election integrity oh yes but we live in
a much better time
right now
we're seeing this happen
all around us
it is this grab of of power these people
using using this moment as an
opportunity to reorder society there's a
story i'm going to get to it a little
bit more tomorrow we don't have a ton of
time to get into it today but stephen
crowder just texted me so i feel that i
ought to mention it they're censoring
crowder again and they always censor
crowder and you might say well it's
because crowder you know look he's an
edgy comedian and he'll yeah yeah he's a
comedian that's the definition of a
comedian they push boundaries they get a
little subversive sometimes but the
reason they went after crowder this time
is because
he was pushing a hateful
violent idea
do you know what the idea was the idea
was that
transgender bathroom policies might not
be all that great for some people
and you know why he pushed that idea
because of a story that the daily wire
broke
because
we said a year ago that we were going to
hire investigative journalists we were
not just going to reinterpret stories
from the left-wing investigative outlets
and take away the bias and actually
present the facts but we were going to
go investigate our own stories
and cover stories that the left doesn't
even want to publish
and we just broke a story
that a girl a teenage girl was allegedly
very very viciously and violently raped
in a bathroom by a man who would
occasionally wear a skirt in a place
where now
boys were allowed to go in the girls
room because of the so-called
compassionate transgender policies and
this was considered violent not because
of the violent act that happened to this
teenage girl violent because we
suggested that maybe boys shouldn't or
they crowder suggested rather maybe boys
shouldn't go into the girls room you're
not going to see a lot from crowder in
the coming week
because of that
these are the people who are controlling
our society we're gonna we're gonna have
to talk to crowder uh this week next
week i mean he's gonna be off for a
little while we'll cover it a little bit
more
tomorrow
but in the meantime we've got to take a
very quick break you know we had a great
time the other night at the ryman
auditorium
it was a fabulous backstage one of the
most legendary concert halls in
the united states we also dropped some
extremely exciting news
the daily wire has a ton of new projects
in the works um we have been keeping
them a little bit under wraps but now
they are out we're pleased to announce
that we have officially dropped the
teaser trailer for shut in this is daily
wire's first original production you
know we had released our first movie
that had already been shot and we
acquired it and distributed it that was
run hide fight well now we've got our
first original production shut in the
film follows a young mother who's
barricaded inside a pantry by her
violent ex-boyfriend and must use her
ingenuity to protect her two small
children from escalating danger while
finding an escape here is a quick 60
second look into a thriller that you are
not going to want to miss
lainey
i told you i need to see you at all
times do you understand me
well i'm gonna take off tonight so the
kids can sleep most of the way well i'm
mostly done i just need to finish
cleaning out the pantry
[Music]
lady
lady
mommy someone's here
get away from him
please let me out
[Music]
very very intense we also want to share
with you a message from the fearless
gina karano whom i love talk about
standing up and thumbing your nose and
not allowing yourself to be pushed
around by very corrupt left-wing people
gina is talking about her new daily wire
movie terror on the prairie which just
started production this week take a look
hi daily wire members this is gina
carano i'm coming to you from the set of
terror on the prairie um we came up to
montana and it is absolutely god's
country we're making new friends
we've attracted the most incredible cast
and crew and a hell of a director we're
gonna make a great
great movie um i'm in love with the
script i'm in love with the character
i'm living fantasy right now so um
i can't wait for you guys to see it
we're gonna work hard
after we announced our first project
this summer the hollywood union started
debating vaccine mandates forecast and
crew and i wasn't into that
i don't believe anybody gets to make
your medical choices for you and i'm not
willing to force maths and vaccines on
anyone else
thank you to all the daywire members you
guys have been an extended family uh
thank you to you know everybody for
making this possible without you i
i don't know where i'd be right now and
right now there's no other place i'd
rather be so i hope everybody is doing
well
um keep fighting
stick together we got this never give up
this is all coming to daily wire in 2022
there is no better time to join us then
now head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe enter code 2022 for 25 off
your membership uh you'll get a new
daily wire membership that's
dailywire.com subscribe enter code 2022
we'll be right back with a lot more
a school in england has
banned the terms good
and bad
this sounds like an onion headline or a
babylon b headline it's not they have
banned the terms good and bad to
describe student behavior
because the headmaster wants to remove
quote emotional words from classroom
management this is at lowboro amherst
school they are now told to describe
student behavior which is either good or
bad
as skillful
or unskillful
the headmaster dr julian murphy says the
policy which he he took i'm not joking
he took it the policy from buddhism was
quote designed to take the emotional
heat out of our language
dr murphy said he did not want teachers
to go soft but he doesn't want them to
be shouty either and he especially
doesn't want pupils to feel
guilty
oh boy oh boy i we have a lot of this
in our country too
don't be so judgy
you know come on don't you can't say
that something's good or what if what if
what you think is good actually someone
else thinks is bad don't you impose your
values on me man we need to use these
less emotional terms skillful or
unskillful
now there's one big problem with this
which is namely that bad students can be
very skillful at being bad
you know dirty rotten students can be
really skillful at being rotten right
you remember this that the kid who was a
jerk in class who was always telling
jokes he was very skillful at telling
jokes and distracting the class
kids who
i don't know they commit crimes they
steal things they pick fights they
perform violent acts in school bathrooms
as we just saw in loudoun county the
story that we just broke they can be
very skillful at that it actually does
require skill to steal and to commit
acts of violence and to do all sorts of
bad things but it's still bad it's still
rotten what what the left is trying to
do here what this school is trying to do
here in england is they're trying to
apply
scientific materialism they're trying to
apply the
the
modern notions of
utilitarianism of of efficiency
really of science to moral questions
okay so skillful or unskillful
because we don't want people to sound
to feel guilty this is what what the
headmaster says i think it's human
psychology even when you're an adult if
you make people feel guilty then you get
angry and then actually that's when
you're likely to play the blame game and
not to work that well that's when things
get into a bit of a vicious circle so
the reason that we have problems and the
reason that people do bad things
according to this headmaster is because
people feel guilty
that's one view of it that's not my view
of it though i think the reason that
people do bad things is one because they
they don't feel guilty
they don't have the sense of sin
or two
because they are not made to be held to
account for their feelings of guilt and
shame
it is very important to have a sense of
shame and guilt and sin i know in our
culture we're told don't shame
don't [ __ ] shame don't body shame don't
shame shame don't don't ever have shame
only have pride don't ever have shame
shame is a good thing
shame is a very helpful tool it lets you
know when you're going down the wrong
path
okay we need a lot more of it we live in
a shameless society we ought to have a
society where people feel a greater
sense of shame the whole point of
education is to teach people not to
follow their basis to appetites and
passions and do whatever they want
it's it's actually
the whole point of education is to help
cultivate a sense of shame in people
because education is not just learning a
few facts from a history book education
is about the whole person it's bringing
up the whole person and making them
capable of their freedom this is why we
refer to the liberal arts and a whole
lot of that is cultivating a sense of
shame and saying don't do that bad boy
johnny no no no more of that be a good
little boy and learn to govern yourself
and then you can be a free person
but the left broadly does not want to
cultivate free citizens because free
citizens are really hard to control they
want to encourage you to run away with
your sexual appetites or your whatever
your your food appetites your drink
appetites your entertainment appetites
they want these things to run away and
master you so that they who are pulling
a lot of these levers will find it
easier to control you and to control the
political order that's not a conspiracy
theory getting back to the comment at
the top of the show
they've been telling us this since the
1960s i write about this in my book
speechless the radical
theorists on the left who developed our
current political orthodoxies they write
about this a lot it's the way they've
attained cultural hegemony and we ought
to take it back
we've gotten so stupid speaking of
education the the san antonio spurs
coach greg popovich
he just said one of the dumbest things i
think that i've ever heard i can't
believe how much sports i have to watch
these days
i'm not the biggest sports guy i don't
think i'm shocking anybody when i say
that i the only sport i like is baseball
and when they went woke last year i
canceled my subscription
i but now i've got i got to watch
football because of gruden i've got to
watch basketball because of this guy
popovich greg popovich seems to believe
that if you
honor christopher columbus who some of
us honored this week
that that's that's no different than a
german celebrating hitler
indigenous people's day
columbus day
columbus
i mean he initiated
a new world genocide
that's what he did he took slaves
uh he he mutilated he murdered
and
we're gonna they're gonna say slash and
honor it's columbus day that's why
they're off
on monday
you know maybe there's something i'm
missing and i'm ignorant
but it makes me feel like they're living
in a phone booth and they're educating
our kids
columbus day
and we're going to honor that
and it's it's it's no knock on italian
americans that's a silly argument
you know it's like saying we should be
proud of hitler because we're german
i mean it makes no sense it's about
columbus it's not about italian
americans
so there's one thing that this guy said
that was true which is maybe i'm
ignorant and maybe i don't know anything
yeah i don't i think he is probably
ignorant and i think he probably spent
most of his school years dribbling and
that's perfectly fine that's that's his
job in his career but he clearly didn't
pay a lot of attention in history class
i'm not going to rehash the arguments
over columbus columbus was a great guy
who did a lot of great things notably
bringing christianity to the western
hemisphere he's accused of doing a lot
of things that he never did and by the
way for a lot of the indigenous peoples
that were here their culture wasn't all
that great to begin with notably the
cannibalism and the human sacrifice some
some people were good people
to to invoke the former president some i
suppose were good people but uh but
columbus was far less bad
and far more good than people give him
credit for and the indigenous peoples
had some pretty horrifying demonic
practices that that columbus and the
spaniards who came after him put an end
to rightly so
but notice the angle here
the angle is this celebrating columbus
if you're an italian is like a german
celebrating hitler which means that
columbus and hitler are the same person
they're comparable and because
you got the italian people you got the
german people and they're both admiring
these guys and so these guys are
comparable right
that that's the argument but it's not
true it's ridiculous it's this new angle
to say that the the person christopher
columbus who is responsible for bringing
our civilization to the new world is
evil
right the embodiment in many ways of
western civilization
is
evil meaning the civilization itself is
evil and when we when we talk about all
these radical theorists who developed
this stuff i know sometimes people are
skeptical and they say michael how on
earth does some radical marxist in his
ivory tower at harvard university
you're telling me that that guy because
he wrote some ridiculous book that no
one has ever really read that is
affecting our whole culture yes it does
have downstream effects in our culture
even to the point that this ignorant
basketball coach is spouting the lies
being pushed by radical academics and
polemicists including in this case
someone like howard zinn
who who is a revisionist
historian he's not even really an
historian he's a political activist it
does have effects all the way down the
line
the left has taken its once in a
generation opportunities every time they
pop up over every single generation and
they've used it to great political
effect and we have not and that's to our
disadvantage
columbus is like hitler give me a break
now speaking of famous painters
how's that for a segue hunter biden is
selling his artwork hunter biden you you
know this
hunter biden uh is
has
given up his life of crime apparently
and drugs and hookers and
selling his father's influence and
selling out the united states now he's
making his money an honest way by
selling his scribbles for half a million
dollars it would seem that some of the
art collectors are not so interested in
the doodles of this degenerate hunter
biden but they perhaps are trying to buy
some influence with the president of the
united states so joe biden was just
asked about this by a reporter and he
brushes it off he laughs as he's walking
by says you got to be kidding me
president biden are you concerned about
potential corruption with your sons
are you concerned about potential
corruption
how's your allergies mr president
are you concerned it's a little bit hard
to hear in this clip because biden
basically doesn't break his stride he
says you got to be kidding me you got to
be kidding me and this is
this is almost more offensive than
hunter biden actually peddling the
influence as he did not just now but for
many many years
it's it's how casual the corruption is
you got to be kidding me come on the big
guy's going to take a little cut off the
top come on what do you expect of course
of course my son's going to sell my name
and sell out the country for half a
million dollars per scribble come on and
you're going to ask me if i'm not even
going to dignify that with a response
and the corporate media won't dignify
that with a response and no one's held
to account for it it's so brazen
it's so casual
it represents how dispirited we are in
this the
or ordinary american people who feel
discouraged and dispirited like we can't
even speak out against this kind of
thing
just detouring back to columbus for a
quick second
elizabeth warren
on monday elizabeth warren lyowatha
herself had the gall to wish people
a happy indigenous people's day as if
she had not built her career lying about
being a native american she goes quote
i'm glad to stand with tribal nations
and native communities as we celebrate
their remarkable contributions cultures
and resilience on indigenous people's
day it's time the federal government
also honors its promises to native
peoples so first of all there's a tacit
acknowledgment in the first sentence
that she is not native american as she
claimed for decades right she says i'm
glad to stand with tribal nations and
native communities
well who are you i thought you were one
of them i thought you were the person to
be stood with
i didn't know that you were the person
doing the statement so she tacitly
admits that but but she it's so casual
she says it as if she had not
gotten her whole career pretending to be
a native american very possibly taking
jobs from actual native american people
who are given preferential treatment in
our hiring process in our school
admission process because there is an
officially legally imposed racial
hierarchy that says that some people are
good uh notably
black people and to some degree hispanic
people and native american people and
some people are bad white people and
asian people what the asians did i don't
know i don't even because the asians are
white supremacists because the asians
have white privilege or something like
that and it's just so casual no shame
from elizabeth warren no apology
whatsoever she just keeps on keeping on
and we are not really allowed to say boo
about it
you know we i saw this firsthand last
night
at
the university of wisconsin
madison
so if you're watching this show right
now instead of just listening to it
you'll notice that i'm not in my usual
studio the reason for this is i'm on the
road with senator ted cruz we're here
taking our verdict show live on the road
we were scheduled to go to university of
wisconsin-madison last night then we're
going to texas a m tonight you can still
get your tickets by the way head on over
to
yaf.org you can
still reserve tickets get all the
information you want there and then
we're going to go to catholic university
in dc next week so the tour began with
this really big hiccup namely the
university of wisconsin-madison
didn't want us to come
and so in the past when when the lib
schools have wanted to kick out
conservatives they have
you know made up bogus reasons security
reasons they would they would kind of go
in and stop the students from reserving
lecture halls and they'd be at least a
little bit subtle about it now they just
literally want to muzzle us so the
university of wisconsin-madison the
administrators of that school the
provost of that school came out and they
said not only do all the students need
to be masked in the audience which is
ridiculous and we were pushing back on
that to begin with they said actually
you michael and you ted cruz need to be
masked while you're speaking
you need to muzzle yourselves during the
event while you're on stage sort of said
you know
a word of it
they wouldn't relent there's an
exemption to the policy if you're
putting on an education related arts
performance that was one exemption in
particular they've given this exemption
to liberals who have come to the campus
in in recent weeks and months but they
won't give the exemption to
me or to ted cruz shows you where power
really lies in this country because i'm
not saying that i'm
i am necessarily the most powerful
politician in this country right who am
i i'm just a guy with a show
ted cruz is a united states senator
going
to give an educational lecture with an
educational organization at a publicly
funded taxpayer-funded university in
wisconsin
and some punk
administrator says no
we don't ted cruz as mainstream a guy
as you can possibly get was very nearly
the republican nominee for president
2016.
no
no he's radical we don't like him no
sorry
sorry guys you don't get to speak here
so we through some really great stuff
that yaf and our team over at verdict
and senator cruz's team were able to
pull off we did get an alternative venue
the school still didn't want to release
the guest list to us they didn't want us
even to be able to be in contact with
the people who were going to go proves
to you it had nothing to do with campus
health it had everything to do with
shutting us up but we were able still to
bring hundreds and hundreds of people to
our event last night we had a good time
but it shows you
how
dispiriting these things can be because
the left has the power and they're not
afraid of anyone this punk provost is
not even afraid of a sitting united
states senator willing to try to shut
them up
as well
even on the left obviously we notice
that this happens when the left tries to
shut us up on the right and youtube is
doing it right now to stephen crowder
and to a lesser degree to me uh you know
and they're the universities are doing
it to conservatives but the left does it
to other leftists when the left
wing people contradict the narrative
katie kirk just got caught for this
katie couric the
very left-wing former anchor of the
today show
has just revealed reportedly in her
memoir going there
that she edited out a comment that ruth
bader ginsburg made the notorious rbg
had made regarding the the athlete
kneeling protests
so when this all started with colin
kaepernick and disrespecting the
american flag and not standing for the
star spangled banner
ruth bader ginsburg the late left-wing
justice was asked by katie couric what
she thought about it and she said the
people who kneel for the anthem are
showing quote contempt for a government
that has made it possible for their
parents and grandparents to live a
decent life and katie couric edited out
those comments this is not the first
time that katie couric has edited out
comments that were inconvenient to her
leftist narrative she did this in a
documentary that she made about guns she
she deceptively edited it to make it
seem as though she was asking a question
and had stumped the pro-gun people she
had like just took
totally different clips completely out
of context and spliced them up so it
looked like she'd asked the person a
simple question about guns and gun
rights and then the the gun person said
you know i don't know it's like
scratching their head but it was just
completely separate footage so she's not
above doing this sort of thing but she
took it out and why did katie couric
take out ruth ginsburg's obviously
correct answer about the national anthem
well katie kirk says
it's because
the the justice was elderly quote
unquote and probably didn't fully
understand the question
so katie kirk just to be kind to rbg
took that out no she i think ruth
ginsburg actually did understand the
question so ruth ginsburg is on the one
hand the most brilliant wonderful
serious tough
jurist single-handedly saving the
republic so strong do you remember they
made that ridiculous several ridiculous
documentaries about her
showing her doing push-ups you know and
they would have some really fit
physical trainer
and he would say oh wow i can barely
keep up with her oh she's so fit and
nimble and she's so smart but then the
minute she goes off the reservation oh
no she's frail
no she's elderly it would be it would be
elder abuse basically to to
put her clear and articulate and correct
answer in this so we're going to get
right she probably just didn't get it
right
right so it just shows you
that not even the left's icons have the
power to contradict the ruling class
all that crap about the notorious rbg
and oh yeah you go girl and wow yes slay
queen it's all fake
they use her they use her as a pawn
they don't use her anymore she's no i
mean i guess now they'll use her memory
but they just all of these people
whether they're celebrities they're in
sports they're in
hollywood they're in the government they
they use them
to advance their
agenda
but the agenda is a generational one and
so yes they'll exploit people and
they'll exploit events and they'll
exploit the coronavirus to totally
remake society
but they've got that clear goal in mind
and they are not going to
change course just because one of their
own says so or just because the economy
goes in a certain direction or just
because the constitution says so the
only way they're going to change course
is if we win political power and we stop
them i'm michael knowles the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
today on the ben shapiro show the
shipping bottleneck continues as joe
biden ignores reality and blames private
companies inflation continues to spike
while the white house downplays the
problem and hunter biden's email scandal
starts to infect joe that's today on the
bench bureau show